leftists everywhere are losing it over
the offer a washington post columnist
saying this quote i am frightened by the
impact on society and politics if elon
musk acquires twitter he seems to
believe that on social media anything
goes for democracy to survive we need
more content moderation not less
all right dana i'm going to start with
you okay okay so zuckerberg says that
this is not about money he believes
twitter should be the open market square
and open source and he says it's
important literally to the future of
civilization you mean elon musk not
zuckerberg yeah elon musk although mark
zuckerberg might agree
who doesn't agree but let's let's talk
about that
well i do love the meltdown of everybody
it's interesting to me that they for so
many many years uh the liberals and they
had a good point they said that they
were for free speech and the
conservatives weren't and now everything
is flipped around and now all of a
sudden when you have somebody say we
actually should allow more speech
and allow everybody to be on the
platform they're thinking no we need
more
control and i also think it's really
funny that so many people believe that
the government could do this better than
the private sector
that will not actually happen i've never
uh i guess that's not the first sort of
hostile takeover that i've ever really
been interested in and watched very
closely i don't know exactly what's
going to happen i do think it's
interesting i wish we could be a fly on
the wall as the employees are meeting
because last week they had to have a day
of rest just because elon musk might
have taken a board seat and he didn't so
i don't know what that kind of sort of
like vacation situation they're going to
have after today's meeting you know
musk greg did take a shot at zuckerberg
uh when asked about speech platforms uh
like twitter being controlled by one
person and then they made the reference
to zuckerberg with facebook and then
instagram and whatsapp so it seems like
musk really has it in for zuckerberg and
he's not happy with what zuckerberg did
i don't i didn't know you know i don't
care about that much i i'm interested in
this new phrase uh content moderation
because it sounds really good we
moderate content here all the time makes
total sense
except yeah geraldo's on then it just
all goes to hell but um it's a euphemism
for censorship right and the thing is is
what what what scares max boot and what
scares cnn is the fact that they might
have to present the other side to their
perspective and that's twice the work
and they don't want to do it it's not
about musk musket isn't going to bury
something like a laptop he's going to
unearth the other uh potential
counterpoints but what you said
hostile takeover it is actually he's
undertaking this is what makes him an
american and a global treasure he's
undertaking a hostile takeover of a drug
cartel
because twitter is the drug that all
journalists are addicted to right the
drug is manipulating stories narratives
to create discontent and division and
they can't get enough of it and that's
why they're so upset that they're going
to lose this drug now he's might be in
charge of the distribution of the
narcotic and
you have to wonder will the press quit
the drug because now he's selling it i
don't think i don't think so and this is
why the purchase we were talking about
the other day is more important than the
purchases of washington post or if you
were to buy cnn no one will or any other
news outlet because twitter is above
that they're the strings that control
the puppets the journalists right
twitter may not be bigger than facebook
or instagram but it's it controls the
people you want to control it controls
the media puppetry he's now possibly the
puppet master and he can decide how to
fix things which i think will be his
first thing is to cancel out the bias by
increasing uh more counter narratives
for that okay brian the wall street
journal says that they are so upset at
twitter that they are they are weighing
a poison pill which is selling
additional shares at a discount so that
uh people can get a bigger uh percentage
of the company i mean they really are
upset about this what happened over the
weekend between musk and that board is
unbelievable also just for the record in
case you do your research after i do gut
felt joe i do call in for a day of rest
yes
and i ask myself why did i do that job
we also we have to bathe i need to rest
right now right okay a couple of things
come to mind i i think i uh i love when
you watch things happen in washington
you know exactly what they're gonna do
you could see this game being played out
we take our sides and we and and we we
stand where we stand i don't know what
elon musk is gonna do it's so good to
see somebody that is ahead of everybody
and i'm willing to say so much smarter
than me so much more i mean i've gone
he's our edison this is our thomas
edison this is our da vinci of our
generation so let him go i do believe he
has a plan b that's something we have to
discuss but i i think this is it when he
got starlink and he put it in ukraine
yes and he saw that he affected the
outcome of a war
he said i have all the money in the
world i'm already making a difference in
space and on the ground in electric cars
i believe that i could change free
speech not for trump and not for biden
but for the country so that's what he's
about i believe that's the big picture
yeah he's all about creating a blueprint
and not following one and you know in
that regard um what about the tesla
shareholders are they now worried
they're saying that their guy is now you
know getting involved in ultimately
politics because free speech is all
about saying i believe in the first
amendment and i'm going to let everybody
talk that means the left is coming after
you but isn't it interesting that the
five people at this table
all are fans of elon musk i don't think
that i own all of us
so look at the bridge of the the scope
of ideology and philosophy that that
entails so the good news from tutor's
point of view is that he values the
company over 40 billion dollars so
everyone's going to get rich the bad
news is that he says that it needs to be
transformed you know i i don't know
what needs to be transformed except that
when trump got thrown off i lost 50 000
followers had it had less more how did
that happen great 150 so i add geraldo
rivera by the way and gerald rivera
[Laughter]
but uh
listen i i trust elon musk i trust him
period i i trust him every one of these
people i would trust him to be president
of the united states but you're the big
investor but don't you think that elon
musk blew up the room he blew up and
said this nobody tweets barack obama
doesn't tweet uh these guys don't tweet
something all these the biggest users
aren't using it he said it's a terrible
play it doesn't matter without musk it's
not worth anything so he blew up the
place if he doesn't buy it he's got it's
in tatters if they if they don't use it
it's their to their except they're there
but i got to tell you one more thing the
saudi prince al-waleed bin tabal
is one of twitter's largest shareholders
he's trying uh to make an offer to buy
it because he is believes that musk with
electric cars is undercutting the power
of saudi oil that's interesting i mean
there are so many levels to this issue
anyone who doesn't like i like you know
what the deadline is for the deal right
what is it
420.
you know what the price he offered
light up greg
we're gonna have a special next time
bring up one more thing yes go around
tom brady has the best sense of humor he
said hey elon if you buy this thing can
you get rid of my combine photo because
this is the most sought after photo
that's tom brady at 22. he obviously met
a super model uh got a tan and competed
a bunch of passes all right thank you
for that hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else